[Music]
welcome back to street talk
today we are speaking with mark serafin
he recently wrote an article called
machine learning
the great stagnation machine learning
phd students are the new
investment banking analysts both seek
optionality in their career choices but
differ
in superficial ways like preferring
meditation over parties
and marijuana and adderall over alcohol
and cocaine a machine learning phd is
now
just an extended interview for fang
which is facebook and google and
microsoft etc
the entire data science interview
process at larger labs has become a mix
of trivia
and prestige checking out a portfolio
takes way too long but checking that you
graduated from stanford
or co-authored a paper with google brain
now
that is a filter he often gets asked by
young students that are new to deep
learning
what do they need to know you know from
a mathematical point of view and his
answer is
matrix multiplication and derivatives of
square functions
all these neuron analogies according to
mark do more harm
than good in explaining how machine
learning actually works
wait so you're telling me it's all
matrix multiplication
always has been he says he's learned the
hard way
that deep learning is an empirical field
so why or how something works is often
more anecdotal
as opposed to theoretical he says that
the best people
in these empirical fields are typically
those who have accumulated the biggest
set
of experiences spending lots of time
doing it
and getting really good at running many
concurrent
experiments age is a proxy for
experience according to mark
if you and all your peers have access to
data centers
this is yet another multiplicative
feedback loop
since you can all learn from each other
this
explains why the most impactful research
in machine learning
gets published in only a few labs such
as google brain
deep mind and open ai the rise
of the transformers the past three years
in particular
according to mark we've seen an
unrelenting
deluge of incremental work with paper
titles that read like
tabloid headlines attention is all you
need
transformers on proteins transformers on
molecules
transformers on images fast transformers
transformers are graphed neural networks
learning to transform
with transformers small transformers
long transformers
he says that useful machine learning
research
on all data sets has essentially reduced
to making transformers faster
smaller and scale to longer sequence
lengths
he says that the bert engineer is now a
full-time job
qualifications include some bash
scripting
deep knowledge of pip waiting for the
new hugging face model to be released
watching yannick lightspeed culture's
new transformer paper the day it comes
out
i think we've all been guilty of that
now haven't we and repeating what
yannick says at your team
reading group it's kind of like devops
but you get paid more
he talks about graduate student descent
and the death of first principles
he's got this wonderful kind of diagram
here which he says is the algorithm of
graduate student descent
initialize find the sotter on archive
find the code on github if worse make
random changes
publish and of course we also have this
publish or perish
thing going on in machine learning which
doesn't exactly help the situation but
he says that graduate student descent is
one of the most reliable ways of getting
state of the art performance in machine
learning because it's fully
parallelizable over as many graduate
students
or employees that your lab has armed
with graduate student descent
you're more likely to get published or
promoted than if you took on uncertain
projects
absolutely it doesn't help that as
kenneth stanley was saying we have
multiple layers of conformalization and
objectives and metrics
it's very very difficult to go against
the grain and actually to follow your
own gradient of interest
because probably you wouldn't be
promoted if you did so he says it's
actually difficult to reason from first
principles because machine learning
algorithms
are very complex with huge numbers of
variability and parameters
where the interactions are non-linear
and unpredictable he says that ablations
help
but even then they're not entirely
conclusive over
such a wide range of parameters another
thing that mark talks about is that
scale
is trivial he sometimes says that he
gets the impression that academics think
that
transitioning to large models goes
something like this oh
python model dot pi hyphen hyphen super
large
if only it was that easy right um you
know there's this kind of conception
that all we need to do is just stack
more layers to the neural network and it
will just magically go faster and faster
he says that you need to worry about the
model and data parallelism
pipelining tuning your hyper parameters
hardware accelerators
network versus compute versus storage
versus io bottlenecks
this is really interesting actually so
every time i interview candidates and
i've been interviewing quite a lot of
people
recently i asked them about a recent
technical
project that they've worked on and the
first kind of question i ask is
tell me about some of the scaling
challenges i don't think it's possible
to work on any application
and not have scaling challenges you know
you might run out of memory on the gpu
or you might be cpu bound or you might
be bound on the hard drive or
it might be latency accessing something
from a blob store in a cloud
there are always scaling challenges and
if you can't passionately talk to me
about what those scaling challenges are
i'm not going to give you a job mark
also talks about
fake rigor he says that it doesn't mean
that he's opposed to mathematical
formalism
if anything he loves maths and he wants
to do more of it in deep learning
he just cautions against fake rigor so
he's talking about
assuming certain nice properties about
data
so that theorems work out you know
gradient derivations that take up
multiple pages of an appendix instead of
just using automatic differentiation
he says that the worst way to do this is
to simply combine
complicated mathematical ideas into a
neural network because you can
you can draw on the reader's aesthetic
sensibilities and discuss
why fourier is the heart of computation
the optimization community is often
guilty of this he says
where they propose activation functions
like swish and then spend pages and
pages talking about the nice properties
of the lost landscape he says the most
reliable way to get new ideas widespread
is to create a benchmark where existing
sotter methods fail
and then show how your technique is
better it should be hard to displace
proven ideas
with unproven ideas this technique has
the advantage of not requiring
any twitter arguments he says that it's
important to avoid
becoming gary marcus and criticize
existing techniques that work
without proposing any better ones which
might work
i'm not sure how i feel about that is
gary marcus proposing any better ideas
don't know jury's out on that one
he says where is the innovation in
machine learning well he says
whilst his introductory lamont may have
led you to believe that there is
no innovation going on in machine
learning that we've settled on a
cargo culting mono culture nothing can
be further from the truth
and he points out keras and fast ai and
he says here that machine learning is a
language compiler and design problem
and i really love this concept myself
i'm a huge fan of francois chorley and
keras
and keras is designed to be a kind of
user-centric machine learning library
and it creates a very very clear
interface and it abstracts away
a lot of the vagaries and complexities
of deep learning
and also it opens up deep learning for
kind of software engineers
and i think that's a really good thing i
personally think machine learning should
move towards
more of a software engineering
discipline and we should focus on how we
can create
an interface and how we can decompose
some of the complex components of
machine learning into
building blocks and we can represent all
of that process and all of that
knowledge
i think that's got to be a good thing
personally so instead of thinking about
matrices or neurons
he was now thinking about layers which
is what he does when he reads a paper
anyway he also points out that
performance versus abstraction is a
false dichotomy
the history of computing is proof to
this right there are many many very
powerful abstractions
in computer science and software
engineering that do not cost you on
performance
he gives the example a fast ai so they
have many different interfaces at
different levels of abstraction
at the application layer they've got a
high level api they've got a mid-level
api
and they've got a low-level api now he
also says an honourable
mention to nbdev which is jeremy
howard's
kind of jupiter notebook environment to
overcome some of the vagaries and
esoterica of jupiter notebook
development and represent something that
looks more like a software engineering
process
i must admit i'm not a fan although i'll
caveat and say i haven't spent a lot of
time looking
into it all i know is that jeremy howard
is a very smart guy i mean
everything he does turns to gold i love
jeremy howard
i mean on on the notebook thing i'm
going to have to respectfully disagree
with him
he also talks about the you know the
promise of deep learning is
differentiable computing
or viewing kind of deep learning models
as being computer programs or maybe even
viewing stochastic gradient descent as
being some kind of
program search and this is what andre
capathi i think originally referred to
as software 2.0 or differentiable
software and i i really like that idea i
think it's a fascinating idea
he talks about hugging face he says what
is the most important machine learning
company today
if you asked him the question in 2018 he
would have said open ai
they dazzled the world with beautiful
demos of agents
besting expert video game players they
reminded him of why he got into
machine learning in the first place
their reputation shadowed everything
but over time it just became their core
product
he says that openai is a media and
service company
just look at the pretty blog posts with
beautiful typography
they force you to pay to use gpt3 he
says that openai
is not a platform company he says that
he can't think of a single large company
where the nlp team hasn't experimented
with hugging face
they add new transformer models within
days of the paper being published
they maintain tokenizers data sets data
loaders nlp apps
he says that hugging faces created
multiple layers of platforms
that could each be a compelling company
in their own right
billions of dollars of value will be
created from hugging face on problems
which are a lot less speculative than
agi
he says that hugging face avoids the
typical ml startup trap
of turning into either a consulting firm
or a citation farm
so at the end of the article he leaves
some parting words
he says that he's incredibly sad to see
that the most exciting work in machine
learning
is coming from outside of machine
learning having spent about 10 years in
this field he now learns more
from crackpot outsiders on twitter than
he does from peer-reviewed papers
so he wants to hear more proposals that
may probably not work
more ideas he wants machine learning to
be fun again
some of you may have seen this article
doing the rounds on reddit just a few
days ago
it's some interesting observations about
machine learning publication practices
from an outsider
so this person was puzzled by the amount
of seemingly weak papers
literally rehashing techniques from the
1980s or even the 60s
and getting accepted and he noticed the
following recipe
so the first one was just the kind of
cliquiness and exclusiveness of
ml conferences he said that the group of
researchers will only ever publish in
machine learning conferences
not to optimization and control
conferences or journals
where the heart of their work might
actually lie for example on a paper
about adversarial machine learning the
entire paper was actually solving an
optimization problem
but the optimization routine is
basically a slight variation of other
well-studied
methods he said that the peers don't
know what's going on
through open review he found that
reviewers not just the researchers were
uninformed about their particular area
and only seemed to comment on the
correctness of the paper
not the novelty and he said he doubted
that the reviewers
even themselves knew about the novelty
of a method
poor citation practices he says that
usually the researchers
will only cite themselves or the other
machine learning people whatever that
means
from the last couple of years
occasionally there will be one citation
from hundreds of years ago
attributed to couchy or newton or
fourier or touring et cetera
and then a hundred year gap to 2018 or
19.
he also talks about the mathiness
remember there was a paper i think
called troubling trends in ml
scholarship which talked about the
mathiness as being a bit of an issue
he says that frequently there will be
massive walls of math
proving some esoteric condition on the
eigenvalue
or the gradient or the jacobian and
other curious things about their problem
under esoteric assumptions there'll be
several theorems
none of which are applicable because you
know the moment they run on their
highly non-convex deep learning
application all the conditions are
violated
hence the only thing obtained from these
intricate theorems and math walls
are some faint intuition which are
violated immediately
and then nothing is said so this person
concluded by saying that ml is a sort of
echo chamber
where researchers are pushing through a
large amount of
known results rehashed and somewhat
disguised by the novelty of their
problem
and these papers are getting accepted
because no one can detect the lack of
novelty
or when they do detect it's only one guy
out of three reviewers
so make sure you check out mark
serafin's blog it's at mark
seraphim.medium.com
and this is where the machine learning
the great stagnation article came from
it blew up on reddit and on hacker news
in quite a few places
he's got some strong opinions about all
sorts of things like for example you're
doing remote work
wrong he's also been working on an ebook
online
called the robot overlord manual which
you can access at
robotoverlordmanual.com
so this manual chronicles his ambition
to kind of teach himself
lots of unfamiliar concepts from math to
physics to machine learning
and he has a couple of principles that
he wants to go by so
he hates problems with no solutions he
hates things that are too long and
comprehensive
he hates sources of information that
don't properly motivate the problem
and things that are written by
professors for professors and once
you're stuck you're stuck
so this particular manual that is
created chapters can be read
independently
lots of illustrations no mathematical
obfuscations
it's using real world julia code i'm not
sure real world and julia belong in the
same sentence frankly but
there you go um embraces other
references evolving and it's free
so the table of contents here is he has
a section on deep learning
reinforcement learning physics software
design patterns
and then there's an interesting epilogue
where he talks about de-schooling
society so homeschooling
how to get a great job technical books
that he loves
how to read technical books a very brief
visual history of mathematics
and a beginner's guide to dungeons and
dragons i think there's a real
art to capturing information in a way
which is funny entertaining
visual and intuitive and mark has a real
talent for that
anyway i really hope you enjoy the
episode today we've had so much fun
making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
and we'll see you back
next week joining us as a guest
interviewer today is dr matthew
salvaris lead principal machine learning
scientist
at irobot previously he was a principal
data scientist lead
at microsoft for four years i'm just
looking through that stagnation article
i swear you've like added more to it
since i last read it is it
it's a living breathing article isn't it
keeps going but there's there's a
hilarious new meme now have you seen the
one with the chad mo engineer
no oh it's brilliant
nice so i'm just going to press record
on my other camera and then we're good
to go
the famous other camera it's kind of
cool with obs how easy it's gotten like
you can basically be a production studio
in your bedroom
okay all right we're going to go
straight into it so welcome back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast
with me your host tim scarf and my two
compadres for today
dr matthew salvaris and yannick
lightspeed culture today we have an
incredibly special guest
mark serafin mark recently wrote a
provocative
article and reading from the article now
he spoke of machine learning researchers
he said that academics think of
themselves as trailblazers
explorers seekers of the truth any
fundamental discovery
involves a significant degree of risk if
an idea is guaranteed to work
then it moves from the realm of research
to engineering
unfortunately this means that most
research careers will invariably be
failures
at least if failures are measured via
objective
metrics like citations now mark you
asserted in your recent stagnation
article that solder chasing machine
learning researchers
now have their cake and eat it taking on
no monetary or intellectual risk
provocatively you said that they are
today's medieval catholic priests
you also said that bert engineers can
command their high salary
with just basic knowledge of pip and an
information
diet of yannick kilche's youtube channel
much like
devops engineers but you get paid more
money welcome to the show mark
thanks it's a pleasure to be here tim i
appreciate it so why don't you tell us
about this article it was a it was a
fantastic article and i'd love to go
through some of the sections of it with
you now
yeah thank you i appreciate it so i
think that the article was sort of a
long time coming like the
actually editing it took me about two
days but sort of
the memes i'd been producing over a
couple of months
and most of the memes independently
weren't like particularly popular
the article itself actually was you know
this was an obscurity for about three
months after i wrote it like no one
really paid
uh too much attention to it um but uh
as far as i was concerned like i mean i
was sort of like starting to observe
like different uh incentive systems like
either either at my work or like my
peers in academia
um and when i started writing them down
like i mean initially uh
the article really started off as a rant
uh but
what i noticed like halfway through
writing it is that like
it actually made me a lot more attentive
to ideas that are not stagnating
like sort of what are some really
interesting ideas in the field and so
it definitely made me a lot more
perceptive i think since then to pick up
interesting stuff
but also a lot more critical when i see
incentives that i
just don't buy and i and i think
generally they're very hard to question
uh like because of this prestige aspect
uh like one example uh
like i like from the article is that
like i called open ai a media company
for example
and i think a lot of people
misunderstood this point because
uh i was actually saying two things i
was saying academia
is a media business so really academia
is not that different from a clickbait
business
and that open ai is a single best
company at doing that
uh and so you know i would still love to
you know
one day like i think open is a great
company i think i've applied there a
couple of times i've been rejected
uh but but but still like i do think
that how like when i look at how much
they inspired me when i was starting my
ml career
to sort out now it seems like they're
doing like these cool flashy demos like
i still feel like there's something
missing that the company
could have been more um and so it's sort
of hard to summarize the article in a
few points because i think there's
there's been
many many points but i i would say like
if i were to have a
more uh you know like tepid title it
could have been like bad
incentive systems in academia uh maybe i
could have written the article in latex
and published it as a position paper
uh but i i figured like the meme format
was a was a lot more
interesting to me i'm persona non grata
at open ai as well because we had gary
marcus
on here to talk about gbt3 so that is uh
game over for open ai
yeah so so i i think the interesting
thing i actually also have like the
opposite position there
where i i i honestly feel that a lot of
people that seem to criticize open ai
criticize it for sort of the wrong
reasons like as in like for me it's like
well it could have been a platform
company instead it's a media company
i think they could do better and i think
they probably realized this but to say
for example like well what openai is
doing isn't real ai because you know it
doesn't use connectionism or
it doesn't use such and such
mathematical formalisms that must be
true
i find this point like borderline
nonsensical because
people still tell me like well like
these techniques don't work well on
existing benchmarks to which my point is
often
create your own benchmarks like
literally think of a benchmark where you
feel
like your techniques have a particular
edge and then publish that
otherwise i think it's very easy to fall
into the trap where you sort of like
fall in love with your techniques
regardless of whether they're useful or
not and so again i think people spend a
lot of time on algorithms and i think
data sets are i think where people
should be spending more time especially
if they want to say
gpt 3 sucks i think that that's
definitely a hard task to do
it's not even clear that that's like i
mean on what time frame it's going to be
wrong
but again i think the data sets is the
fastest way to go about proving
open ai team wrong without needing to
resort to twitter flame wars
i mean what i what i found so
awesome about the article is that you
put in words something that
many of us just know to be true
but never you know managed to to
formulate like you'd spout out one or
two of these points every now and then
but but to to compress it into look
here's what or here is like a giant
problem in the ml community
in in in words and in memes is just
it it's i think you know the success of
the article
is due to the fact that it instantly
resonates with anyone
in the field you know you talked a bit
right now about the incentive structures
could you maybe give a brief summary of
what are the incentive structures that
you criticize
and and why so i think like historically
you know like if you look at like what's
really the function of academia like
there was never an expectation that
academics would be rich for example
it was more like you're a nerd like
you're in love with these techniques
and academia provides like what i call
like a downside hedge
like as in you know like you're not
going to be on the streets even if your
uh your research doesn't work out and
you know if it does work out that's
great
and then if you do this over a hundred
researchers uh one of them is going to
have uh
i wanna one of them's gonna have a great
career the the point is
is that it that on the aggregate you're
guaranteed to have one successful
researcher
but at the individual level you're not i
think instead well what's happened is
that
uh well i said one thing that i really
like about machine learning is that for
the maybe first time in history
the average scientist is becoming
wealthy and i think this is actually a
very interesting dynamic and one reason
why i see so many physicists or
biologists that are very talented
going into machine learning and i think
like great so now not only do you have a
downside
hedge you actually have a great upside
and
with this great upside you have the
luxury of being able to take
great risks and instead of taking them
you're basically saying like well you
know you're basically coming up with
excuses as to why you can't
and so really you should just be honest
with yourself at that point and say well
i don't really care about science like i
just care about having a great salary
and at that point you know this is sort
of like when i talk to my friends in
banking for example they're usually very
honest they're like i'm like well why
are you in banking they'll tell me
you know i love making lots of money and
i think that's a totally valid thing to
say
like at least you're being honest but if
you say like no actually i love the
puzzles
and i love the science but you know
actually your actions are saying
something different you're saying you
like you love the money um and so
there's a couple of consequences of this
i think like one of them is the sort of
uh like there's like complexity becomes
a built-in feature by sota chasing
why like let's say if you were to look
at the like the the
the birth forks you know a lot of like
roberta or former like they're all like
bird force like actually you can even
see where the fork started on github
which is
i think uh amich adora has a nice
article like showcasing this
so great i mean you have these forks and
you're gonna add stuff right and and
you're let's say you know ask them cool
stuff you're like oh i'm gonna add a
fourier component or i'm gonna add a crf
or
you can think of all cool sound i'm
gonna add like an energy system
um so you try enough of these ideas out
one is sort of bound to work
just like by what we know by by b value
hacking
which means that now if if you have the
compute to try lots of stuff out you're
almost guaranteed to find
something that works especially now if
you take it at an aggregate level which
is like let's say all of google or all
of facebook is doing this
it becomes very easy to come up with
something great so now you have a new
state of the art that is very difficult
for people to verify
uh because it's very difficult i mean i
i actually know zero people
that have ran from scratch all of the
famous birds like i know zero of these
people
i'm sure they exist somewhere maybe like
in some of the centralized language
teams at larger companies like microsoft
or facebook
but for the most part uh we we take
these things for granted like
as in uh i like i'll say something like
long former is good for long sequences
not because i've actually ran up just
because like i've read the abstract i've
i've looked at janik's tutorial i'm like
yeah you know seems about right like
this is like the
like this is how this is how it scales
and the number of sequences
and so it's just become very easy and i
think as opposed to like doing science
like i think we're sort of becoming like
hype chasers
uh almost like with a religious vibe
where like you know like
the medieval catholic priest reference
came about because it's like
you know this authority said this is
great therefore this is great
and i think the the sort of like first
principle thinking is really going away
and i think people say like it's going
away well because because the techniques
are expensive
uh yeah like that's why you have to
trust the central authority because you
can't validate the stuff yourself
but it doesn't mean that you like i
think this position of
only uh you know expensive ml
with like lots of data like large models
like that's the only interesting thing i
think that's sort of like just a lack of
imagination
because if you look at the outskirts of
ml there's lots of interesting stuff
happening especially in the compiler
space or the tooling space
the math space there's a lot of
interesting ideas going on you just have
to be willing to
not not be rich and i think that's what
it comes down to
it isn't like though the part of the
soda chasing i completely agree with you
an effect of the review system as well
so you know if you send a paper and if
it beats sota you're
or almost guaranteed to get it in
whereas if you don't have any sort of or
if you create your own benchmark as you
said
it's going to be very hard to kind of
get that new idea in there
and you know it might take you years to
kind of get the idea then
and then if you're thinking about the
fast pace of the way things move
that that could be that's forever in
someone's scientific career
so so i i think this concern can also be
addressed by incentives very easily like
i think the way i see this address
regarding publications
is people like well i don't know cc the
chair of neurops and be like
don't you agree that like like the peer
review system is broken
and that it's just better to publish
stuff on your own blog post and like
what's the reviewer gonna say
probably not like because the reviewer
has an incentive to say
this this structure is good and so i
think like people are asking for
permission for people
uh from from authorities that they
admire to say is it okay for me to
publish on my own blog post is it okay
if it's not in this
archive format that's like eight pages
long where i have like nonsensical
introductions for three pages
like is it okay that i i publish that by
myself when really the answer is
you know it's it probably is just do it
and stop caring
but what happens in that case is that
you have to be okay with losing out on
some upside
which from an individual perspective i
often don't recommend like let's say
you know like if you want to solve
science like okay like
don't don't go work at google but if
you're like in your early 20s and you're
broke like of course you should go work
at google like you should go make some a
few money
uh get some backbone like like meet some
friends
but once you have that downside has like
once you have that
a few money use it otherwise it's not
really a few money
so very often in kind of research one of
the kind of
like stepping stones is once you've
moved on from a postdoc is that you have
to put in a research grant
okay and usually with your research
grant you're not gonna get
like from some outlandish idea that
that's for for you know tenured
professors
you're gonna have to do something that
is kind of in vogue um
and you've kind of got a new spin on it
so that generally science
always moves with things that are in
vogue you can't like you know if you
spoke spoke to the people who were doing
neural networks you know jeffrey hinton
and the back in the dark ages of
neural networks you would say like
they kind of really avoided trying to
put neural networks in kind of their
grants
proposals because people would just be
like nope
and kind of no power of it so i know we
definitely have a faster pace of it in
machine learning and that's kind of the
nature of machine learning because it's
an empirical driven science
um and so therefore it's just always
about experiments experience experience
but i think is it just a general trend
in science because it's just
it's just a simplification it's how
people are able to easily say yeah this
is a
is a good idea because everybody else
saying it's a good idea
yeah so so i definitely agree with you
uh like and this is like
how things are today uh but but let me
challenge that for a second so
like if you were to historically look at
uh you know so one of my like
as a teenager i was really into german
philosophers and one of my observations
at the time was like wait a minute like
all of these guys like come from really
really rich families not not like
a bit rich like sort of like fifth
richest person in in all of europe kind
of thing
uh and so i think this sort of like then
tells you like okay great well
you know if you're rich then you can
sort of pursue this like gentleman
scientist like lifestyle where you don't
really care about what's what's in vogue
and or not
and you can pursue it however like let's
say pre-internet
uh like let's say you have like
governments for example like controlling
like how things should get funded so you
would write a grant proposal to some
sort of central committee
and the central committee then needs to
decide like is this worthwhile or not
and if you look at today for example not
only is it
difficult not to get like if if you're
in any field of computer science today
based on some some of my peers that are
doing their phds uh
they can't get funding for anything
unless there's the word deep learning or
neural network anywhere in there
regardless of the computer science field
like it sort of has to be there
and this creates like sort of a
monoculture like incremental improvement
however i think there are today
many many wealthy uh you know ml
researchers
uh and i think what you can do is
instead of like let's say appealing to
the nsf
you could find someone you really admire
on twitter who's really rich tell them
like look this is what i'm gonna do
here's my github repo you know do you
mind just like paying me for rent until
like i figured this out
and i would bet that this model works
pretty well um
and i mean i'm not i don't have that
kind of money myself
but definitely once i do or if i do
it's definitely something i want to
pursue uh like a lot more strongly
because i think it's just very easy
right now and and because like i can
identify today
many people that are 17 on github
that are just absolutely monstrous
engineers like ten time better engineers
than i am
even though i'm 30. uh but they they
don't live like in san francisco like
they live in
random places they didn't maybe they
didn't go to school but you can see
their output
it's very obvious like these people are
very talented and they don't have a good
channel into academia
because then they need to like today you
know have already a bunch of published
papers
uh even though i would question like why
would you need to go do a phd if you
already have published papers you're
already a good researcher at that point
you know you're even more independent
than most phd students like 10 years ago
um so yeah i mean like i definitely feel
like the patronage system
uh needs to make a comeback uh and i
would also encourage like i mean
like i had a recent blog post called
like the sovereign student
and it's sort of like it's it's a
spin-off of a concept i i call it the
sovereign researcher as in
instead of asking for permission like
you know start your own conference start
your own journal
start your own blog write your own
papers don't really care too much about
what authorities scare and then just do
stuff that you think is interesting and
find the peers that you think would
resonate with this
but if you ask the question well how can
i make the nsf care about like my
obscure functional programming library
for deep learning well i think that the
answer is clear like they don't care
one thing about github that reminded me
of my conversation with kenneth stanley
and he said that we have a tyranny of
objectives and we have all of this
conformalization
in every aspect of our lives not just
peer review and science but
github actually is an example where
folks can follow their own gradient of
interest
they can fork any repo they can they can
do their own thing and then if it looks
good and other people find it
interesting then other people might fork
it
i mean it's not a patronage system and
of course these people still need to
earn money somewhere but
it is actually a remarkably open-ended
system isn't it
absolutely like i think for me uh you
know like when i think of uh
like mastery as in you want to become a
good researcher
i think like a fairly reliable path uh
that's a good alternative to
education in general uh is you say okay
well i'm gonna summarize other people's
work
so let's say for example you start a you
start a channel like yannick
but you know as a virtue of summarizing
lots of stuff eventually you understand
lots of stuff and then you meet other
people that are interested
in the stuff as well so great so so now
the next step is to say
okay great is there like a contribution
i can have here and it's like is there a
library i can produce and then it's like
great well you know
and eventually well out of these one of
these libraries can one of them help me
make a living
and i think of it like well you know
like i like
okay so about uh three years ago like i
left my uh
you know very high paying job at
microsoft uh to just figure stuff out
and at the time i didn't really know
what i was gonna do i thought i would
start my own company
and i sort of spent two years trying to
figure out i guess what i wanted to do
and it seems like a lot but then when i
thought about it a bit more i'm like
well like i spent sort of 20 years in
education and i still didn't figure out
what i wanted to do
and so i think like uh it's sort of like
we we never actually get that that many
opportunities to have self-directed
exploration
because we're chasing metrics as in like
i need to
graduate school i need to get a good sat
grade i need to go to masters i need to
get a
high paying job at microsoft and so as a
result i think it's sort of like built
in
that you know like we don't have
self-directed exploration
i think a big part of it is how long the
education system is
uh i think it could definitely be made a
lot shorter maybe two hours a day
instead of eight maybe like four years
instead of twelve
i think it'd be a lot more reasonable i
think it effectively functions like a
like babysitting i think i think that's
the primary function of like lo
of like the early education system
because parents work and they need a
place to put their kids
but i think if we are honest about that
like this is the real function maybe we
would design it a bit differently that's
why i find like some of the montessori
approach like very
very interesting and so i think this all
really relates to each other like i
think we're used to having goals our
whole life
and all of a sudden we're told well like
now if you want to be really successful
don't have goals
and that sort of creates like a like
you're like wait air air like
this this sort of doesn't make sense um
and also i think keying off of like some
of the stuff kenneth was saying like i
think
it's sort of interesting because i think
we're in different positions in our
career like anna's
is is a leader in this company so he
needs to figure out like how to make
other people innovative within the
company
but then like his answer is also well i
like i can't have goals
but then you know what's the goal of a
company it is to sort of also make
revenue reliably
and the best way to make revenue
reliably is to also have goals and then
execute on them
and so so there's a sort of like
friction there where i think again
uh for a company it's like well you know
build
build cash by doing boring stuff and
then use that to fund
your more speculative r d and similarly
for the individual like make a few money
as early as possible early in your
career
and then use that use that freedom like
as you as you get a bit older
but sort of don't get caught i guess
like in the rat race because you just
end up
optimizing for a metrics with
these kind of alternative
routes you're describing i fully applaud
this and
i personally know some of these you know
young researchers that are just
producing
incredible outputs and is very cool but
it it is almost it is very much going
into the direction of you have to be a
media person a media company
something like this because now that you
know the centralized apparatus falls
away
you have to actively make other people
aware of your stuff and
i mean you can produce you know great
things and no one cares
if you don't go out and be kind of like
hey look
and so on so um where where does it
where are the goods and where are the
bads right
this is a great point so like i
personally think
that kovid has been the single biggest
opportunity
in history for engineers that know how
to write
like here's the thing like i sort of
learned this the hard way
uh you know when when i left my job at
microsoft i was trying to think okay
well i want to make a reinforcement
learning service for game developers
like i love games like reinforcement
learning is like wow i got into ml in
the first place
and so like i would like code a bunch of
random and then like i would reach
out to random people
and they'd be like like who are you like
off like or just not answer and
like at the time i wasn't that good at
cold emailing people and stuff
and i had like no twitter audience like
you know like my facebook was mostly
like family and friends and stuff like
just posting
uh and so like i quickly figured out
like wait a minute like it sort of
doesn't matter that i have all this
stuff like i don't have a way to tell
people about it
uh and so actually late into uh
like about like later into the second
second late into
my second year of doing this i started
to just sort of get like burnt out and i
was like okay well let me just sort of
start writing down
the stuff that i learned working on my
company yuri and so that's how
my ebook came about robot overlord
manual and a couple of my chapters
went viral as well on hacker news and i
was like wait a minute like this this is
a big deal because now people are asking
me like oh how do i do game ai
do you have any recommendations like do
you want to work on this thing together
and so it was sort of like the marketing
channel of my dreams
even though that wasn't the goal at all
it was a consolation prize because i
couldn't be a billionaire from my own
startup or a millionaire or whatever
so like for me in my head it was a
mental failure but actually ended up
becoming more successful than
me grinding on some code that no one no
one really cared about
uh so i think that's uh and so when i
started writing that
initially my first couple of chapters
were what i would call
cookbooks like they're like here is a
concept and here's this concept
explained in the simplest way possible
maybe with some accessible diagrams and
accessible code but what i realized is
that like often
like the more of my personality that i
would inject into the content
the more people resonated with it and
people are like you know like let's say
when i started like talking about like
homeschooling or the modern education
system this was pre-covered
uh i i i realized that the responses
were very polarizing like
me writing about homeschooling was the
first time people got angry at me for
something that i wrote they're like how
dare you say this is the right thing or
like
what about like you know what about like
if your parents can't afford
homeschooling or
and people got angry at me for all sorts
of reasons
but what it also made me realize was
that well like it definitely meant i
resonated more with people
and so i think the great stagnation post
was the first time
that i tried to sound like myself like
for my friends that know me like this is
sort of how i talk in real life
uh like like i sort of have like these
takes all the time and this is how
i view the world as always like via
incentives uh
and and it was by far like i think my
most successful
uh and and and polarizing like either
people loved it or hated it
and even the people that hated it often
hated it for reasons that i felt where
it was like almost like a projection
where it's like well i'm a
prompt engineer how dare you say this is
a bad thing and i'm like well it's okay
you can be a prompt engineer make some
good money then
figure out some other stuff and so i
think
writing for me is definitely my
strongest suit like i'm a much better
writer than i am at my other
media pursuits but uh it made me realize
that it's good to have a process around
this stuff like let's say when i read
papers now
i stream myself reading those papers and
then i'll have like a
little edited video on youtube and then
i get a lot of people reach out
typically for my youtube content it
tends to be people that are earlier in
their career
starting out learning ml but for my
written content it tends to be more my
peers
and i think it's just a reflection of
how i write like when i write i'm
writing for myself so it's other people
like me but when i make videos
uh often like in my streams one thing i
thought was hilarious was that uh
like i'll be streaming something a paper
and it's my first time reading it
uh but i'll still sort of figure it out
you know because like a lot of the math
looks similar a lot of the ideas look
similar
um and it's also why i think uh you know
i i also get excited these days when i
read papers
that are different like by different i
mean take me more than a day to parse
uh so i got this for example with a
recent paper by facebook like the graph
transducer networks paper like it was
sort of a hard paper like it took me
some mental
uh you know like i could like bend my
brain a bit to get it whereas like if i
were to read a new birth paper often i
can read it in about 30 minutes
uh regardless of what goes on i don't
have to understand every single detail
but just as a high level idea here's
here's what happened
why do you think companies like google
facebook microsoft
continue to finance this incentive
structure because at the end of the day
right they would profit the most from
actually you know having great
scientists that do take risks and so on
and the downside of course of what
you're saying is that
nowadays you don't have to take risks
you can sort of put or you know
put more compute at a problem and so on
get better
state-of-the-art why do these companies
continue
to finance this is it profitable or is
it a hype does it collapse at some point
uh yeah so i think there's sort of two
points there like one
it seems to be reliably producing
benefits
right so it seems that like let's say if
you were to think of companies like amd
or intel like
they make their processors like
incrementally better every year
uh that that seems to be enough like you
don't really need breakthroughs to have
a sustainable business maybe you can
just have eight percent appropriate year
over year and still be a billion dollar
company
so that's totally fine uh i i think sort
of like i'll flip the question though
and say it's not that microsoft
itself is deliberately saying please do
incremental research
what's happening instead is that as an
individual
like i need to think okay well like i
get you know
evaluated on a quarterly basis or a
yearly basis i really want to get
promoted right i want to make money i
want to
become a manager so that like i can get
more respect for my peers and be cool to
maybe get poached by another company uh
and so
like if like the thing is like if i were
to do incremental research
and it succeeds great everyone's gonna
call me very smart
if i do incremental research and it
fails no one's gonna tell me
well look what you did here was really
insane but if instead i'm like you know
what this deep learning stuff is
instead i'm gonna
go down this like really bizarre route
and if
that bizarre route likely will not yield
anything
uh you're gonna get fired like i mean
it's gonna be like well why are you here
like i'm just gonna get the other person
to take your job that produces results
more reliably
so so i think it's individual incentives
that are sort of
causing this local optimum it's not that
these companies are
uh it's like you said they have the most
to gain by making these techniques
cheaper
like one thing i will say though i mean
this is maybe a bit me putting my tin
foil hat on
but uh like the thing is like like
if you're a cloud company like you can
effectively print money
at this point so you don't really care
about stuff becoming cheaper as in like
yeah you care about it because it makes
stuff cheaper for you
but it's not like existential to your
business in the same way as if you're a
startup
and so i think like because the the
downside isn't that big a deal like from
a competitive standpoint like you're not
going to lose out that much by doing
incremental work
plus the individual incentives highly
favoring
incremental work means you just get lots
of incremental work
yeah i completely agree with you i think
it's very much driven by the individual
but also kind of
the the these research labs in these
companies are in and inherently just
mirroring what's in academia that's what
they know that's what they've seen as
research and the researchers from
academia go into these organizations and
they're like okay how do i incentivize
oh papers okay papers so how many papers
you get so therefore it's exactly the
same incentive structure so
of course we're going to get the same
kind of results and as you said
like the the really the people who will
in these big organizations are the
people who are
might be more established who are like
okay i'm i'm happy now
like i've got i'm i know where i am i
you know i don't care if people call me
stupid if i pursue this for the next 10
years
like if i get fired so be it but you
know maybe there's something interesting
at the end of it
and so it's never going to be the
individual kind of starting researcher
or junior researcher that's going to do
this
so i think what you're referring to is
like a few money or a few reputation
it's sort of like you don't care that
you can do whatever you want and people
people will trust you
i just feel that a lot more people have
already been in that position and not
recognized it like if you look at a lot
of top researchers
making six figures maybe even seven
figures in a lot of places
like they have this luxury but then
they're not really uh using it to me
which feels
very very disappointing um but
i i guess yeah i mean like incentives
are too strong like it's just it's very
hard for you to put this brain on and
say
i don't want short-term recognition from
my peers i want to work on like bizarre
stuff i think that takes a very peculiar
kind of person and i'm not sure how to
sort of inject this into people's brains
organically i think it's a very hard
problem
what's tragic about this is we know from
reinforcement learning
about deceptive search spaces right
we know that we need to be going in
the opposite direction of what we think
is the right direction in order to solve
that maze
but for some reason we still go on the
way we're doing it
we're doing something a little bit like
epsilon greedy and reinforcement
learning but the big companies aren't
even doing the epsilon greedy part
they're kind of socializing that for the
people in their garages or
smaller companies that are doing random
things and then they'll just acquire
those companies as
and when they do something interesting
and there is a little bit of delusion
going on because the companies will say
oh you know that's not true at all we're
investing in quantum and
blockchain and neuromorphic computing
and all this stuff
what's the deal there yeah like i i
think you that's on a couple of
interesting points
uh so first like maybe let me bash on
neuromorphic computing a bit
but uh it's essentially to me it it like
it's sort of like these
these uh you know uh hypotheses that are
treated as fact like well of course if i
build something like the brain it's
going to be better you know
maybe like maybe not and i even feel
like uh you know one thing i i tell
friends is that i feel like the word
neural network
is sort of a misnomer like i like to
call them matrix networks i think that's
a lot more
actually representative of what actually
happens and then you get rid of like i
think this neuron analogy that i think
has been for the
for the most part holding us back
basically here like
i call this uh like core porn like as in
like it reminds me a lot if you look at
like gaming hardware for example
we have like 12 cores or 24 cores and
it's like this epic thing
but again it's the wrong metric like i
don't care about that like i care about
like can i run this
at i don't know how many frames per
second on this specific game
so it's really the end level metric that
i care about or it's like well i care
about this end level task performance i
don't care how many trillions of
parameters you have
it's sort of like so tangential but big
numbers are impressive like i mean we
have this bias like we think like wow
like that that's a lot like
i mean i i don't even know what a
trillion is and who's to say that's a
lot or little like who the hell knows
it's like why not two trillion why not
three trillion like it's sort of like so
or like why not like a 10 million or why
not 100 million
so so i think like the the way this is
being used is that it's a successful
marketing channel
and in fact like i mean it like i i
don't know if you guys have observed
this like on twitter i get a lot of ads
by microsoft research which is like the
most bizarre thing and they're like
advertising certain papers
and i think this because this feeds into
the brand as in like look we're doing
cutting edge work
look at how great this is we're so
innovative the numbers are going up
people in marketing love this because
it's reliable like it's like
i can always do a new posting like oh
it's bigger than the last one like oh my
god it's even
closer to the brain than before like wow
and so i think it's just you know again
like and and these
these articles get read uh the ads get
clicked
people summarize them people build off
of them so it's not like they're even
being posted in a vacuum like people
are are talking about this work they're
they're building off of it
and so it seems to be working fine which
i think makes questioning the incentives
very difficult and takes i think very
long-term thinking
uh you know which if you were to look at
let's say like the average tenure of
someone at a large tech company which is
what like maybe two to four years or
something
um yeah maybe you're not incentivized to
think like 10 20 years in the future
it's sort of
so irrelevant you'd rather get like
multiple quick promotions early in your
career
then like i know become like very very
senior and highly regarded somewhere
else
get a large team and because the field
is inherently so empirical
it matters a lot like it's sort of like
it matters that you have a hundred
scientists on your team versus ten
because that's a hundred more students
that you can paralyze experiments over
uh and and because there's sort of this
inherent like p hacking aspect going on
it works very reliably and so you you
want to get to that point as an
individual
and again i think it takes a very
peculiar kind of person to to not care
about that you have to be like the like
gregory perlman kind of type to not care
about the stuff
which i think is a very unique character
trait like i've met like you know i
don't know two people like him
in my life so it's not like something
that i can say a lot of people think
they're like that
oh i don't care about money but then
their actions often say very different
things so i mean don't look at what
people say look at what they do
and what they do seems to be working
fine so they're just gonna keep doing it
let me challenge you on this a little
bit in that you know you're saying
something like
you i don't know more parameters i don't
care how many you know
how many transistors you have i care
about then and so on but
something like gpt3 was genuinely
astounding like in in the final metric
of let's build something interesting
because i like people are now saying
things like i think what gpt3 is doing
is intelligence i did i i heard
no one say that for gpt too like
regardless of what you think about it i
heard
zero people say this of gpt too right
something like
dolly is flashy but is also
very interesting like so there's
definitely like
some some kind of interestingness
appearing
of soda chasing off scaling up and so on
and that that is
actually one of the features of deep
learning maybe what's really interesting
about dali
is it gives us a lens into what's
happening with gpt3
now yannick and i were desperately
searching the internet trying to find
all of the things that that came out of
gbt3 we were convinced that
this must exist somewhere on the
internet but with dali
it's actually generating hamburger
snails
or avocado chairs or you know things
which we know for sure
don't exist so being able to visualize
that in in some ways it makes me
think that you know as a kind of text
generator gbt3 really is doing something
quite interesting there
um by the way like i i actually i
actually agree like i mean i i've said
this in
in in the stagnation post like i had a
mimified version of
susan's bitter lesson uh which is like
like basically the version of the meme
was you have the first year student
going like hehe you know cue learning
make agent go vroom
in the middle you have like sort of the
like the the researchers like well i
have to regularize the entropy in the
following way and then you know
like the the galaxy brain researcher is
saying uh you know like most benchmarks
are bs
you know like the the best techniques
are the ones that are easiest to scale
and so i think for me actually um
because i i never
actually got to experience the magic of
gpt3 myself like i
i saw people posting stuff about it on
twitter it looked really interesting
but i can talk about something that i
did experience which was playing against
like open ai's dota bots
and i can tell you like it was insane
like i'm i'm an avid dota player
and i was playing against the bot and i
really literally felt like a buffoon
like i
just was constantly getting outplayed
like manipulated into overextending
being like you know one percent of my hp
before i die
and and so there is something absolutely
outstanding about it i mean it it works
and it and it's
great and it sort of beats all the rules
that you want to encode or all the more
like math that makes us like warm and
comfy uh
like yes but but and and and here's the
butt it's sort of like well
you know you can have two positions to
this right you can say like wow this is
magical let's keep sailing up like
that's great
our like let's have more tasks that we
care about like let's say dota or you
know maybe just look at problems outside
of just images or languages
or you could say like no this doesn't
work because it doesn't use
connectionist logic and i think this is
sort of a
almost like a nonsensical position the
other position which is which is to
think like okay this is really
interesting
uh what can we do besides just scaling
it up
i think is also interesting because i
mean at this point scaling things up
is i'm not going to say it's trivial
like it is hard it's not like you just
say python
make make model big and you know that's
just how it works like you need to think
about it how to distribute it think
about like
good like paradigms for distributed
compute uh
there's all this stuff but this is not
what i would say
like generally our problems academia
excels at like these are problems that
industrial labs excel at it's sort of
like
i know how to make transistors you know
that's great you can probably do that in
a lab but like how do i make a billion
transistors a second
that doesn't seem like an academic
problem like that's more of a like
that's more of a process probably an ops
problem right
and i think industry is very like
usually very good at solving those kinds
of problems
and so that's how i think of it gpt is a
very interesting industrial problem
i just don't think of it as something
interesting for academics to work on
unless they were to come up with some
unique ideas that actually
work not that they think will work and
just don't work
uh and beyond just like i don't know
tagging along on papers where they're
like well we make this big
and and i think one thing i thought was
really interesting is if you were to
look at the
new switch transformer paper for example
like it had three authors which i was
like very
which i i thought was very intriguing
and i think part of that is because like
well like
like a lot of the work is reusable like
let's say being able to scale up models
like the codes reusable
the infrastructure the distributed
dashboards like this is an
this is a very important asset uh
and i think it's actually sort of the
core competi like that's the most
i think for companies like open ai like
part of the mode is the people
they're very smart and that's why the
companies continue producing very
interesting stuff
but i think another big part of that is
the infrastructure is very it's very
good
and is reusable like i highly doubt
they're just running python scripts from
scratch and
hacking together a bunch of open source
code for the first time like i really
doubt that's the case
uh so so that's really my answer there
it's that from an industrial and ops
standpoint
some companies are shining but i think
academics have shown a surprising lack
of interesting ideas when it comes to
scaling up these models
isn't that also because a lot of the
academics are are caught in these
companies
and i almost feel like maybe what's your
opinion on this
a lot of times i feel like these labs in
these big companies
half of it at least is just people
grabbing it's like
you're really smart i you know what i
don't want you to work for my competitor
so you know go in my lab do whatever you
know
you like do something do something do
some bert and uh i'll pay you a lot of
money
it doesn't matter what as long as you
don't work for my competitor
are we is is that a problem or does that
actually
i also also feel it frees people up to
do sometimes
things because they're pretty
comfortable there but how do we
incentivize that
even more of these kind of interesting
ideas yannick and i were
offered a potential job recently for an
absolutely incredible amount of money to
rebuild something like gpt three
four i thought it was incredible but it
was
it was the fat end of a million dollars
a year to basically recreate gpt3
i think it was some kind of as you write
it will give you helpful suggestions
type startup it was unbelievable
i mean but but let me let me flip the
like why would
you take it for a year for example so so
can you walk me through your process
that makes you walk away from a million
dollars a year because i think
you'll probably answer your own question
by answering that like
well as i said i've i've played with
gbt3 my position is the same
i think it's a so interestingly this
particular application the only reason
it would have worked is because it's an
interactive application so it's there's
a human in the loop
gpt3 will only ever work for interactive
applications
and even then how the hell do you
constrain this thing it's gonna
literally just depending on the words
that you write it's gonna say something
completely different depending on how
you sample it
keith said there's a wonderful slide he
shows to all of his customers about
cyborgs
so humans and ai are better than just ai
and there's an example of chess so you
know if you have the human ingenuity
and the chess algorithm uh just to kind
of touch about your point about uh
dota um so like i followed a lot of the
starcraft 2 and starcraft 2 and soccer
forum were kind of
my games and i think they did a
fantastic job and kind of watching
um alpha star play was absolutely
amazing
but they didn't beat any of the south
korean like top tier players they didn't
even come close
and also if you could have watched some
of the games on youtube you would see
that there is
it played really well and so did some
amazing strategies but it had some
really big faults
that you know these players would just
take take them apart that basically that
the computer would have no chance okay
yeah definitely for kind of
mid-tier and players like myself it
would completely destroy us
but for for really really like top-tier
players
um it would just have no chance at all
isn't that just a function of how much
you limit this ai because like the ai
can always cheese you with insta
reactions and so on i know like in dota
it was like able to instablink you know
once you
stun it and stuff so i feel i feel this
is
gaming ais like this are almost beside
the point because you know if you just
unlocked
all of the capabilities of the ai it
could you know instantly destroy you by
just
microwaving you away or you know insta
reactions and stuff
so i don't know how much you know how
interesting yeah
i don't know how yeah actually so the
alpha star would actually play as
protests a lot and would basically use
blink stalkers
and so precision with blink stalkers
would actually destroy anything
and they even they did limit the apm the
position was still too high it was much
higher than any human could possibly do
it
so even if they did bake in lots of
limitations they still found that the
like the the kind of ai let's say the
machine learning algorithm
did kind of learn to exploit these
specific things that played to its
strengths
um and it's not to say like you know a
mouse and keyboard for a human isn't the
ideal
input system either so oh so so i also
saw the blank stalker live and i agree
with you like something about it felt
off
it's kind of like like no human can
really do this this doesn't feel like
this doesn't feel
fair uh for dota like like but that's
not what i
felt for dodo like i think with dota i
genuinely felt like
this machine is a far better player than
i am
i play the game a lot like i'm not i'm
not a pro but i definitely have a lot of
time in it and the game did beat the
best team in the world like they beat og
at the time
like two times ti champions uh and and
then the bot was only beaten after they
publicly released it
like thousands of people were able to
play against it and then people found
some vulnerabilities
and i think this to me reminds me a lot
of just metas in general so like i've
been a competitive game player
for for a long time like since my
childhood with chess and it's sort of
very similar like when you get a new
world chess champion come up
everyone studies their games and like
they'll just like study everything and
they'll know exactly how to play against
them
and then the next generation of players
sort of knows their strategies
knows the counters and has to come up
with new strategies
and i think something like this is very
similar in that like maybe if you open
source this thing
and one time like put it out to
thousands of people
some people are bound to find some
exploits but i would say the same would
be true for any pro team
like a pro team can't actually play
thousands of games versus
thousands of people at once but if it
did i think it's very plausible that
a couple of players would find like some
was
some things that these players are very
weak at and learn to exploit it in the
same way that we would exploit machines
in this regard
uh so i think if anything machines are
are judged more more harshly
uh than humans are in this respect
that is related to something else you
touch in your article
and namely i'm thinking okay everyone
can play this everyone can figure it out
but
something that i do touch on in your
article is these this this
nowadays this reliance on resources and
compute and so on
where you precisely argue that not
everyone can figure
stuff out anymore and yes we could you
know we could as academics go to the
fringes of machine
learning and do different ideas but if
we want to be engaged in the core
nowadays
it seems like we have to have access to
a big cluster and
google will rent you a tpu but it's
going to cost you like 10 times as much
as their
internal true cost right so what
what are your comments on this and you
see do you see a way
forward with a different incentive
structure that
academics can play in the main game or
should exit should academics just kind
of be creative
in what problems they tackle uh yeah
so i will say like the the best answer
is uh like
like what nasim tariq calls the barbell
strategy so
that means like look like you're gonna
make good money by you know making birth
faster or like uh
prompting birth so like like why lose
that on the opportunity
like use i don't know like 70 of your
time to to just do
what sort of the market wants you to do
and make good money with it
but then like use the time and freedom
that you get
especially as you get older i think this
ratio should be adjusted down so instead
of doing 70
incremental stuff start doing maybe 20
uh and then
this bible strategy sort of gives you
the best of both worlds as in
like yes your upside isn't guaranteed to
be as big
but sort of in probabilistic terms if
you get like a big payoff then you can
benefit
and you're never going to be on the
streets like you're never going to have
to go
i don't know like you're never going to
be jobless like your skills are always
going to be relevant people are always
going to understand what you're talking
about
but you know invest a bit and i think
it's sort of like part of what makes
this advice funny is that it's not like
it's not i mean it's what my grandma
would say right it's sort of
like you know pursue your side hustle
research and have your main job
uh i i think that's something a lot of
us can do because like and there's a few
reasons for it like one
uh you know i i have part of my meme
when i talk about data scientists like
you know
reading papers is really an intellectual
form of procrastination i think
it's like you're saying oh i'm working
kinda yeah you are but you know you can
spend all day reading papers and
thinking about the nature of
intelligence
doesn't mean like anything is being
produced and so yeah you can do this
and and and do a fraction of that for
your day job but use the time and luxury
you have to to do
uh more interesting stuff i think maybe
also your question could be well how can
we encourage this at a societal level
i don't have a good answer for that like
maybe i will one day if i'm a manager
myself and i'll think about how to
encourage these incentives in a team
but for now i like to think of it like
from an individual standpoint
this is a good strategy if you
are interested in stuff but you don't
want to lose up on the ups like on a
guaranteed upside of
a nice salary because i think it does
matter i think you like
before you do anything interesting in
life like build a safety net for
yourself i think should be
like it's a very obvious thing to do but
i think i think we over intellectualize
it and forget how fundamental this
aspect is
can i maybe amend to the question
because my question was more like
what does a phd student at i don't know
atlanta university do like what does
you know what does the the professor do
who isn't associated with with google it
it almost seems like
your path would be go to google make
money then do phd
but what like what do what do
researchers outside of these
outside of these compute laden
money-laden
uh big boxes do yes so
so i will say then the the best approach
to get started here
is to build uh you know like summarize
stuff for people
and build libraries around it so become
a media company
and that way the prestige doesn't matter
as much like the thing is
i think people don't get about prestige
is that you know
yes the internet has democratized stuff
but prestige still matters like i mean
it it's it's it's it's almost
instinctual like if i look at a
background and i'm like someone went to
stanford i'm like
probably smart you know and this is very
difficult for me to unlearn this because
it's sort of built in
and there's a self-fulfilling prophecy
here like if smart people think that
other smart people are going to stanford
stanford it's going to have more smart
people on average than other schools
so prestige matters and if you get the
luxury of going to a prestigious place
you should go especially if you're early
on in your career that said
if you didn't get the opportunity to do
this it's not over
you have other paths but they're
trickier and i think that the best
most reliable path for people who didn't
go to prestigious institutions
is to become media companies and i think
that's very feasible for people because
you don't even need original ideas
actually to get started
all you need to do is start summarizing
stuff in an interesting way
and by virtue of doing this a lot you're
going to have more interesting ideas
meet more interesting people
and use it as an incubation period for
you to build open source software
one thing i thought was really
interesting so at one point i got
rejected from a job i wanted
and if the feedback i got from the
hiring managers like well maybe you
should do more open source libraries in
your spare time
i'm like great i'll do that so then i
started looking at open source libraries
and i realized like wait a minute like
there's
really a couple of hundred people in the
world that are carrying open source by
themselves like pytorch has like
three people numpy is two people julia's
maybe like
six people that do like 80 percent of
the work
and so i think it's sort of an excellent
ideal to strive towards to become a
popular open source library maintainer i
think it takes a long time and my
observation at least has been that
on average the people that i meet doing
this successfully tend to be older than
i expect
like they tend to have been doing this
for a long time very persistent
and they tend to have found some way of
having a downside
hedge like as in either they're
independently rich their spouse is rich
they they they got they they had a
startup exit early on in their career
so i think that really helps but yeah
like i think the more downside heads you
have the better and once you get it
i think you want to pursue these
ambitious goals but just recognize that
it's very hard just by virtue of the
numbers like
like if i were to say like i mean let's
say you were i don't know some sort of
like nefarious country and you want to
just like destroy software
uh there's really a couple of maybe a
few hundred people that need to be hit
by a bus and you would destroy
all software for like 20 30 years you it
would take a long time to recover that
intellectual capital
um yeah i know also like i often
like kind of that general idea of
creating a library and maintaining it
and open source on github
um it's a lot less visible than writing
a blog post as you said or as you said
being a media company
like the number of hits that you'll get
on your library is just going to be so
miniscule especially if it comes becomes
quite niche
you have to make it quite general as you
said like if it's more approachable
content that's on youtube
you get far much more engagement kind of
through those kind of avenues than you
do through
some library on github unless it becomes
huge
it's sort of what makes me uh feel that
like i think
conferences are dead uh i think this
whole concept of networking is dead
i think really the internet is sort of a
vehicle for for nerds to meet uh and i
think people don't use it that way
and i think people still treat it as
like let's say you know i have a recent
article where i call people linkedin
bots and what a linkedin bot
is is a person who has no opinions they
just share
pr announcements uh but instead like i
think if you're
willing to take a risk and willing to
maybe be wrong or imprecise in what you
say
you can be it can end up being a lot
more interesting and then attract
people to you and make friends and i
think that's also one of the best ways
to learn like because
i mean i have a question actually like
that i ask people that like like when i
was just starting out on twitter and i
was in and on
when i would ask famous people like
what's your favorite book on topic x
i found that they answered fairly
reliably even when i was like an and on
with a
you know an anime picture as my profile
picture it's just like people don't care
like it's a good question
i think what people really hate is like
hey do you want to exchange
notes or do you want to connect then
people sort of tense up they're like
well i'm busy like what do you mean
like what do you want like what do you
want are you asking for are you trying
to sell me something
but if you're just saying like look i'm
interested in this really niche thing
that you did
uh here's why i think it's interesting
did you think about this did you do this
people tend to be very responsive and i
think it's just like
it's almost like people need to become
better at cold emailing people but i
think a big part of it is being
interesting and valuable to the people
that you're reaching out to and it sort
of flattens things like i mean if
if you go let's say work at a big i was
early on my career at microsoft it's
very hierarchical
you know there was like nine people for
me to get to satya if i were to jump up
the hierarchy
so it doesn't like you don't necessarily
feel like you could just email satya and
be like hey dude like you know what do
you think about
x uh and again i mean you're probably
not going to be able to reach out them
on linkedin either
but you can get pretty close like i
think like let's say i i had for example
a tweet that's sort of summarizing an
interesting paper by jan
and you know he jumped on and gave some
feedback about how he thinks auto div
compilers are and i'm like that that's
kind of interesting like that's not
something i thought was possible
if i didn't have a large portfolio of
papers
and that beyond read my work and
approves of it like i can just have an
interesting tweet that took me you know
two hours to write because i read this
paper
uh you know and then have a connection
with one of the people i admire the most
in the world like i think that's very
powerful and something that people don't
use quite as much as they should
i think it's quite difficult not to do
that in a manipulative way though
i have so many people connect with me on
linkedin and sometimes in the preamble
on the connection they actually say they
want to sell me something no that's
great i can just say no straight away
and almost always that you know it comes
later which means i have to put them on
mute
and sometimes there are some slightly
manipulative ones where they say oh hey
tim i really enjoyed your
video on kenneth stanley the other day
um by the way i'm selling an ml devops
product
can i grab 15 minutes next week and then
i get about 100 messages from them
so so so i think another aspect is maybe
like like uh
like your respective audiences have
gotten large enough
where you you're never sure like are
people connecting with me
because they want something out of me or
they just genuinely interested in me
so i think like maybe uh like often for
like let's say in the functional
programming community that do ml
it's a very tiny community uh generally
like when people reach out to them it's
also just because there's not enough
people interested in this stuff
so that can end up becoming more
targeted so i would say like find
interesting people that aren't famous
it's almost like investing right like
trying to think about who's going to be
interesting in 10 years
but if you try to if you're going to
look at who's investing right now who's
interesting right
now there's all there's always this
doubt in your head and i can certainly
see
why you would think it's manipulative
especially it looks like the emails you
got were very blatantly manipulative and
i would probably not respond to those
either
you quickly mentioned kind of
willingness to be wrong um
and i think that's a very big thing and
it's something that
well permeates a lot it permeates the
culture generally
not just kind of just science but just
generally people
really kind of don't want to be wrong
and so therefore they
that makes them expose ideas that
they're just regurgitating because i
can't like so and so
they're really famous and whatever they
can't possibly be wrong
but also at the same time it means that
kind of they're
basking in the glow of that rightness so
to speak without having to kind of
force their own opinions out into the
world and have people say no you're
wrong
so i think that's a very interesting
point so so i learned this lesson
about a year into my career like very
hard in a very difficult way
so i was working on a bi system for ads
at microsoft
it was my very first project out of
school like all i knew was math and then
it's just kind of like okay well
deal with lawyers and m a's and
consultants and marketing and finance
and it was very a bizarre experience for
me
and i remember like there was no
architecture diagram like all the
knowledge was in people's heads
no one had written it down and i
complained about this a lot you know i'm
like well i don't really understand
what's going on and the feedback
resounding feedback i got from my peers
was
it's okay you'll figure it out you'll
figure it out by osmosis
so what i started doing was i would
start like almost like compulsively just
taking notes and meetings
thinking well if i just do this for long
enough i will eventually figure out how
this works
until i had one of the more senior pms
on my team
who i'm honestly forever grateful for
who like looked at me while i was taking
notes he's like are you here to take
notes or make decisions
and like i almost like tear it up like
it was just like i felt so humiliated
but after that the meeting he sort of
took me aside he's like yo let's talk
and he like
bought me coffee and he's like look you
know i think this a big part of this is
that you're too scared to be wrong
here's what you should do do an
architecture diagram that's wrong
and share it to everyone who works with
you and tell them this is how things
work right
and then they're going to tell you of
course not like this is wrong in the
following this is wrong in the following
way
so he taught me very early on that like
look share the wrong thing and people
will correct you
and it's something i've experienced over
and over again like at some point i
wrote an article about uh lagrangian
physics
lagrangian mechanics which is sort of
this optimization way of doing
physics like you minimize an energy
landscape uh
and you know i'm not a physicist i'm an
ml person
and the feedback i got from a lot of
people was like i i shared it on hacker
news it was it was pretty well ranked
there
and i had many physicists that were like
look you made it something and you said
something incorrect here you should have
said this instead
here you know this is a mistake you're
coding the wrong reference this doesn't
make sense
and i would just say thank you and i
would fix it and i'd be very grateful to
those people and share them the feedback
and obviously if people are trolls you
know they go like well like how dare you
as a machine learning
person do physics i just go kind of like
and i would also respond in a trollish
way to just be like you know like
don't mess me but don't mess with me
kind of thing but when people were
willing
to give me candid feedback i was very
grateful for it
and uh yeah i mean i i think it's sort
of
you know like like again like i do the
same thing now with my videos like i'll
say wrong things and i'm like wait a
minute like
i'll figure out what how everything
works out like in the 50th minute of my
video
and then i'm like okay great i just need
to scrap this whole thing and now i can
explain it
uh so so i don't know why people have
this bias i think maybe it's school to
like i don't know why like
perhaps it's school and grades and stuff
but yeah
i can understand it a little bit i i
have it myself that i i want to be
polished and i want to understand things
and i want to iterate on things and
i i quite often used to say when i was
younger let's not be busy idiots
let's be really smart about this and
figure out what we're doing but there's
something to be said for just getting
something out there as quickly as
possible you know doing something crappy
fast
can be better because the kind of
feedback that you get from that diverse
audience out there is actually going to
be far better than anything you could
have
done on your own and it also for me sort
of nullifies the benefits of peer review
like i think
the internet you can sort of self-select
your peers uh
i don't actually know any physicists in
in
in my day-to-day life that could help me
correct give me feedback on a post about
lagrangian mechanics
i know a lot of people that i've never i
just know them by their usernames
that happily give me long-form feedback
which is insane to me like these people
exist and i think part of it is that
i i've realized a lot that even though
like ml is very popular
the amount of people that have
interesting and original thoughts about
it is very small
uh and so like like you'd just be
surprised like i mean even mouse is huge
popular
physics maybe is even less popular but
but these people exist and they're
willing to give feedback as long as
you're you're also interesting
and it also makes this point around like
let's say like a lot of people
uh you know and i i was guilty of this
when i was first starting twitter
it's like you know i would tweet
something and then tag the same thought
pretty much on every single one of my
posts
and like looking back it's like the
cringiest thing because like i'm looking
for approval for someone that i really
admire
uh and i think just getting rid of this
and being like look you know i think
it's probably interesting like let me
just post
if people wanna i think it's interesting
they'll like it uh you know instead of
being like a sort of like an insult
about it and blaming other people for
why you're not interesting
they figure out how to be more
interesting and i think it's a
worthwhile pursuit
you said something really interesting a
second ago which is that you think very
few people in the ml community are
actually really driving the innovation
and i just wondered what do you think is
the distribution of of talent and what
does that mean because you we were
saying earlier quite cynically
that there's not much talent we're all
sort of chasing and we're just
doing incremental improvements and we're
doing the
uh you know you called it the um the
students gradient descent didn't you
understand yeah that's that's right and
silicon valley in particular which i
think is is very near to where you are
there's this mindset when hiring
software engineers that if they can't do
coding challenges and don't know about
data structures then they're crap you
know and there's this prevailing mindset
that only one in 100 software engineers
are any good
do you have the same opinion about
machine learning do you think there's
like
a few really good engineers and everyone
else is not very good
um yeah like i will say that there's
lots of engineers but i would say
less than easily less than one percent
of people in ml
probably probably i would say maybe even
closer to 0.1 percent
uh so so i think it's just like there's
just like inherent power laws
and i think like the thing is about
power laws is that they're inherently
uncomfortable because
they don't give a good distribution of
outcome to people
uh however it's a function like look
like your attention is a finite resource
right like
you can read any paper you want so
you're going to naturally direct this
attention towards a small fraction of it
and we're all going to be basically
reading the same papers by the same
people doing really interesting stuff
that doesn't mean that there's always
like you know the the heretics you know
at the outskirts doing stuff that seems
totally insane but it's totally
interesting
um that's why i mean i have this concept
that i call like a sovereign researcher
which is a researcher that you know just
does things by themselves
i think one really important thing that
a sovereign researcher should do
is help crack bots flush out their ideas
like i think that's like you know like
it's like make them more precise don't
just be like oh you're a crackpot like
be like like what is it really that
is turning this from an interesting
thing to a non-interesting thing
um and i think like you also mentioned
the point on interviews i actually
recently wrote a new blog post on
like the what i call like the myth of
objective tech screens
and i actually detail in very painful
detail a lot of my personal tech screens
and basically how they effectively work
as rubrics like it's sort of like
i ask you a bunch of questions like
what's the best uh you know what's the
best loss function well you know like it
depends or like
can you do this or do you know what yolo
is and i'm like well i know what resnet
is and unit and i think i think i can
figure out yolo it's like
but do you really know what yolo is i'm
like no
like yes or no like i might well know uh
and so i think like
there's this aspect where uh well if
we're just gonna be interviewing people
by rubrics what ends up happening is
that you
effectively uh test for stress it's like
like how how good were you at sort of
doing the sat at like reading a bunch of
top concepts in ml and doing them
whereas i think like really
to sort of get to the more interesting
parts of tech interviews
i think inherently they need to be more
subjective and by subjective i don't
mean do i like you it means
tell me sort of about like your proudest
project and let's talk about it a lot
like let's talk about like why you find
this exciting this
is unfortunately very subjective but to
me it gives me a sense of like
does this person like have a spark in
their eye like do they care about the
stuff like do they care about making it
better
or did they just sort of do what their
manager wanted them to do which i think
is
unfortunately very common like it's like
either my manager told me to do this or
google told me that i should be doing
this so always looking for an authority
to get permission to do stuff
is just generally i think very
widespread
and i think it's just shockingly painful
how few people don't do that
could i play devil's advocate on that so
let's say google and facebook they do
have a very calibrated interview process
and they do that on purpose because they
want their process to be scalable
replicable
calibrated basically so that they'll ask
you the same questions and they'll
formalize exactly what answers they
should have and they design the
questions in such a way
that even if you knew what the questions
were in advance
they're testing your understanding and
they're testing your communication
skills and so on and so forth now
and i can come up with some fairly good
examples for software engineering but
perhaps
mark and matthew what kind of interview
questions do you ask
during machine learning actually so
obviously i
like always the basics just
understanding and i always try to probe
where their strengths are so
looking at what they've done in the past
and also kind of just figuring out by
answering
by getting them to answer questions that
should be what
they should know but beyond that to
mark's point one of the my favorite
questions is
i always try to leave time at the end
and said is there a paper or a set of
papers that you find really interesting
and why is that interesting and what is
it because exactly to mark's point is
if they're really interested in doing
the research if they're
they will have this they will find
papers they will be excited about
something
that might not be mainstream especially
like they get extra marks if it's
definitely not mainstream
and it because it shows that they're
willing to go out there
and pick these pieces of information
together and invest the time in
in going through the papers uh and not
being um
so they're kind of common term as
armchair scientists where they're
basically just reading papers and never
doing anything
um but they're not kind of just armchair
scientists they're kind of trying to
draw threads together and go okay i
think it should be
this this and this are the experiments i
would do they could be complete failures
and if they did the experience and they
were completely fair
great but you did something you thought
it through
and you thought how you could move
things forward and i think for
a scientist or a researcher i think
that's really really key yes they need
to know the basics yes they need to be
able to do
or whatever they need to do but they
need to be able to kind of think outside
the box and think how they could
possibly extend things
so so to sort of key off of that i 100
agree and that
for me i don't particularly care about
weaknesses i think they're
sort of overrated like i i'm really
trying to figure out like
like what is this person good at what do
they care about and so i think like
richard hamming had a good
uh question for that which is like sort
of what's the like what's the most
important problem in science and why
aren't you working on it
i think this can be adapted for as an
interview format which is like
let's assume that you could work on this
dream problem of yours
walk me through it like you know how
does this work technically how do you
how do you make money off of it you know
like how how do you know that it's
getting better
like what what could be some issues that
you could foresee well what about memory
what about speed
so sort of like pick a very specific
niche problem that i know the other
person is interested in because i asked
them what they think is the most
interesting
and then just attack from all parameters
uh
my worst interviews were the ones that
are like have you heard of technology x
have you heard of technology why
uh those are just very bizarre because i
mean like
it's sort of like like i don't spend my
day just surveying technologies all day
like i think if you are that kind of
sucks too you should
find better stuff to do in your time but
i think the interview process sort of
actually encourages that
that said a lot of it can be gamified
like actually when people tell me
oh how should i prefer an ml interview
there's a book called the hundred page
ml book
that i think is great and then maybe the
you know data science from scratch by
joel rose other also another great book
you know speed read those books and then
go on google like okay
see what is a transformer what is a
resnet
you'll probably pass uh you know a
fairly average like data science
interview just that way in a couple of
days
could i um gently challenge so much
because you've said on you know you've
got your chad ml
engineer meme and one of the things on
there is that you know you basically say
that reading papers is intellectual
masturbation you say you know
procrastinates all day reading papers
but but you you do advocate
you know you just said you know like the
100 page ml book and you've got a
wonderful
list of of books so where do you draw
the line between intellectual
masturbation and actually you know
useful reading online
yeah so so i think it's all about ratios
right like as in like if
like i think people get into tutorial
hell very easily in ml
it's like how do i do cnn mass rcn and
how do i do yolo okay how do i do
transformer from scratch
and then they just like end up in this
tutorial hell uh or they just end up
reading all the basics and then
it's like well you could spend like
maybe 30 years reading the basics and
you'll never be done
and so i just think of it as again it's
sort of like an explore exploit paradigm
where
you're running the stuff yourself you'll
very quickly learn stuff like wait a
minute like these loss functions don't
work very well
oh like these optimizers work better i
really need this dashboard oh my god
early stopping is very useful
oh mixed precision is is great to make
this faster but it makes my loss like
diverge
so the first principle aspect is is so
important and because the field is so
empirical
it's sort of like your core like this is
your emote like this is your personal
mode like your set of knowledge
is not what you've read in tutorials
it's like the personal experiences
you've had from failed experiments and
successful experiments
so getting a large body of experiments i
think is very important
and then of course again this goes back
to the barbell analogy
like when you are reading random stuff
like you know go crazy you can
you can you have the luxury of reading
whatever the hell you want so why not
read the interesting stuff
for example like when i left my job uh i
i i had this long list of book
books that you're referring to tim and a
lot of it did feel like intellectual
masturbation until i started summarizing
them
then it became something real like then
it's like oh wait a minute like now i
have the only
like let's say i wrote a tutorial about
automatic differentiation it's now like
the top entry on google if you google
for automatic differentiation so
something i was very proud of
because i mean yeah lots of tutorials
existed they were all very dense they
had lots of math
or they explained it too high level away
so
turning from something from a thing that
i know
to an asset that just grows while i'm
sleeping
was one of the biggest uh you know
achievements for me
uh like the biggest realizations that i
had like in the past year has totally
changed how i work like it's like i try
to have
as much of what i do be publicly facing
because it makes it better
uh and it turns it into useful assets
for me so i i don't
read like i often rewatch my videos or
my tutorials at this point because i'm
like oh how does this thing work
oh wait i'm like this is pretty good you
know like i feel pretty i'm like well
this is actually garbage i need to edit
it
which is why i do frequently re-edit my
documents i don't treat them as this
thing that i just do and never look at
again like even my list of books i
change
every month or so there's a new book
that comes in or comes out of that list
so
but it seems to help you having it all
online it makes you accountable
yes because the end of the day this is
self-directed learning and i'm very
impressed with your passion and and your
energy and
i have it as well in in a sense but you
know
i'm running this youtube channel so i
have to be interviewing people every
single week and keep on top of it
um would it be the same if you were just
completely on your own would you still
be self-directing your learning
at the same time i mean like it doesn't
have to be a hypothetical it's what i
actually did for two years
between microsoft and my current job at
graphcore
uh i don't think it's for everyone like
i think it it's basically
it you have amazing ups where you're
like oh i'm a god like i did this by
myself but then
you get really bummed out and you're
like oh why am i doing this like my
friends are getting promoted they're
making a lot of money
i don't have millions of dollars yet so
so i think like
it's very hard uh day-to-day because you
don't have like a tap on the shoulder
telling you a good job or that was good
mark good for you
however uh sharing it online gives you a
shortcut so now like i mean
as soon as i started doing that i never
i don't care about
get people giving pass on the shoulder
anymore it's so irrelevant like i know
that when i write something whether it's
good or bad in fact like let's say in in
my post
like the stagnation post i wrote it
three months ago
and i actually had a live stream where i
was writing it live and i was telling
the people who were watching in it's
like i told them i'm pretty sure this is
going to be a popular post like i sort
of knew deep down this was better
than other stuff that i wrote because i
just i'm honest with myself or other
times when i'll write a post i'm like oh
this is a cute post it's not it's not
gonna you know blow people's minds it's
interesting it's okay like i'll post it
and so generally like i know like i
trust my gut feeling more
uh and i think like again but but but
but i wouldn't have been able to just be
on my own for two years
had i not had a really nice salary at
microsoft so again i think this idea of
a safety net really matters
because it gives you more options like
you don't have to use them but but you
can and i think
a lot of people just don't they just
sort of settle into a very local optimum
where they're like oh i don't like my
job i don't like my team
i don't like the city and then there's
like are very fatalistic
um you know i met so many depressed
people my age when i when i worked at
microsoft and it's just kind of like
i i think it almost felt like i get it
like i resonate with it but at the same
time it to me it often felt like a lack
of imagination as in
well you know i don't you don't have a
girlfriend you hate your job
you know you don't have friends uh you
know you don't really do you don't have
hobbies like you know you're probably
gonna be depressed like it's okay so
take some actions that let you do more
interesting stuff in your day-to-day
life and
you probably won't be depressed and i
think sharing stuff online is a good way
to
to do that again it's a good shortcut
for a lot of these things
i mean with respect to sharing your
stuff online i want to
challenge you a bit there as well
because you know i
i started my youtube channel in
well in 23rd what i really started
uploading my first videos i think in
2017 or so
and no one cared like it was even though
it was new it was the first
like paper explained channels did not
exist
and now there is even like copycats
right like
one copycats which and a huge honor
honestly but it did not exist and for
years no one cared and i just sort of
uploaded it as a procrastination for
myself because
you know i i thought you know maybe
it'll help it'll help someone
and that is it seems like it's a bit of
a bigger problem because
most people you know when you say you
have to become a media company you have
to become a media person and so on
most people just due to that pareto
aren't going to succeed like how many
and people are trying to game this now
right people are trying to like write
medium tutorials where you just
know this is written so kind of they're
all nice
and so on and they suck right a lot of
them it's like
it's like clubhouse right like not
everyone is interesting
but like probably i mean
everyone has interesting things to tell
but just you know make like just doing
a big conversation where everyone puts
their opinion out there
that's not interesting so everyone sort
of has to find their own
niche yes but i feel this whole media
thing it doesn't work out for most
people or do you see that differently
so so inherently you're right like i
think what you're referring to is
attention is finite so you get these
burrito distributions where
you know like your channel has like what
70 000 followers mine has 400. so
there's like sort of a big gap where
it's like well there's some people in
the middle but but it takes time because
a lot of people just let's say rather
just watch the more polished one
and there's a feedback loop because as
you do more you get more accountable you
get more feedback you get better you get
so there's just like so many feedback
loops that mean that the more popular
content
is often actually better but
i think that people have tried to game
it in a way that's very lazy and
and this is what i call like the two
cookbook tutorials as in
like let's say i read a chapter from
some author like let's say you
read the chris bishop book you read a
chapter and then you'll just basically
put it in a medium article and you're
like
great this is how like you know
multi-linear gaussian
and and it's very obvious you're not in
this field you have nothing to
contribute you're like why are you doing
this
however i think that's why being more
genuine is interesting like let's say in
in my case for example like am i as
famous as gary marcus like you know
probably not
am i one of the most widely cited like
open ai researchers my you know also
probably
not but i think what worked about my
post is that
it was written in a way that i hadn't
seen other people write because i i
deliberately made it sound like me
like this is how i talk like i swear all
the time i make fun of all the time
but i also love science so it's it's
maybe it's not that unique of a venn
diagram
but you know combine that with people
that enjoy writing all of a sudden like
i'm one of the few people
producing content that's like this and
it resonated with people
and so i would say often it's very scary
but sounding like yourself is very
important and
okay so great so now you're like well i
i have an expertise like ml
so now how do you sound like yourself i
think the best way to do it is to copy
authors you like and so the authors that
i admire the most are nasim taalib
george orwell and chuck bolanyak they
all have like this irreverent style that
they write in
uh it's all like satire but talking
about the real world
talib is actually has like math you know
so it's like also kind of mathy
and so initially you're like oh i like
this like why do i like it well i like
it because it resonates with me
so you copy it and then by sort of
jumbling them all together
you sort of end up with with your own
unique voice uh and similarly to your
memes like let's say uh
and all of your cases that you make
jokes you make memes uh you know you
could have tried to sound like yan but
you know you're not yon
you know let's be real like yan is you
know more accomplished more successful
more contributions to the field so if
you were to compete with them directly
there
you're going to lose out like jan's
going to capture most of the attention
but like well let's say yan doesn't
produce that many memes he's not
interested in doing videos
so instead of trying to be the best at
one thing try to be the best at a whole
cross section of stuff and you're likely
to be the only person competing with
yourself in that case
and so that's why i think for for this
post like let's say when i think about
my cookbook articles
i can definitely see competition as in
oh like this is other
here's this other automatic
differentiation tutorial is it better
than mine
whereas with my stagnation post i know i
don't have competition because i don't
know anyone else that sounds like this
like i don't know any other ml article
i know a few actually that have memes
but not to this extent and not like as
uh i guess as critical
and so it makes me comfortable to have
found my niche i think more people can
can do it and if anything i feel that uh
you know one of the most common
questions i get asked after should i do
a phd or not
is how can i become a better writer and
so i tell people
one step one write step two try to sound
like people right like tell me about the
authors that you like and if you don't
have any of those
then it's very hard uh but again like
let's say you you may like a fantastical
style of writing like sort of
a dreamy like well you can combine that
with ml that's sort of a unique thing
you could talk about ml in a very
historical way like you know
looking through the history that's also
very interesting you could talk about it
from a systems perspective
that's also very interesting and you
know these are all very obvious like
these
people exist like i can think of people
that have a cross-section between
systems and ml
i can't think of many accomplished
writers that have this cross-section of
skills
so maybe in 10 years it will be more
crowded
but i don't think we're there yet i
think people just haven't been writing
enough about their own unique
experiences yet
and i try to encourage people to do it
more because i i feel like i found my
voice like maybe
it's sort of like this again like i said
it's irreverent style being critical
sharing way more personal detail than
i'm generally comfortable
sharing but what i've generally found is
historically i did stand up comedy
i also do a lot of my friends wedding
speeches it's often the jokes that i
really wanted to take out
that were by far the most successful or
am i should i say this this is a bit
much like i shouldn't make this kind of
joke or like maybe people get angry at
me here and then when i keep those those
end up becoming the most successful
my latest article on interviews was like
this because it's very personal like i
mean i i literally shared
about like 15 different stories of me
being told like you suck at ml and
software
but it ended up becoming very popular
among a lot of people i shared it with
because they're like oh like
i felt this you know so it's like great
well if you all felt this like no
no one wrote about it i only see people
on the glass door
talking about like oh i made half a
million at facebook like you know you
don't have the
other people saying like the more uh
giving a more interesting take on what
may have happened or
reflecting on their own personal
failures or reflecting on maybe the
the failures of the people interview the
people the failures interviewing them
so again uh i i think it's we're nowhere
near saturation
but you say that you kind of like nassim
talib like reading your articles
i i got that i i could tell that you
definitely either
have read quite a bit or you do like him
as an author so it definitely comes
through
thank you yeah i mean that for me that's
the biggest that's one of the biggest
compliments you can give me so thank you
appreciate it
yeah i do like some of his books
definitely and what you said before
really resonated with me as well
i think being yourself and finding
yourself
um with yannick as well you know he is
his unvarnished self on on youtube
it's he doesn't edit anything and over
time i've been learning to edit less and
less
and at the beginning i would edit out
many things that i say
that actually are my character and and
are me
and i think the the art is it takes a
long time to find yourself online
but when you do find yourself just
present yourself as you are
and and that's actually what people like
i i sort of think of it like the hero's
journey
it's like you're a link and you're
looking for like you're like the master
sword i think it's very similar
but i think people don't undergo the
journey to try to find themselves
um and they just end up in local
optimums but but yeah
i think i'll end on that indeed well uh
mark serafin it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for joining us this
evening
tim yannick matthew thank you so much
it's a real pleasure be sure thank you
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments
and we'll see you back next week